شو اسمك
فاطمه بدلعوني بطه صفوني اليهود وانا قطعت
رجلي من القصر وتصور اخويا اختي الكبيره
حبيبتي ماتت الود حرام و انقصف في يوم
23/11 يعني ما يقارب قربنا على
الشهرين تصبوا اولادي كان اصعبهم فاطمه
بطه دلوعتنا
والحمد لله
ربنا فقدنا انبتت لها رجل يوم القصف مفاجا
الطفل صغير هذا تحت ركام اربع طوابق واحنا
بعذاب لما طلعناها طلع في رجل البنت
متهتكه كثير فيها ت تهتك عظيم وعدوني
الاطباء انه ممكن يصير لها تصليح لو تسافر
بسرعه وضعها نفس كثير يعني تدمر كانت كيف
وكيف صارت لاين بتعرف بتطلع على الاطفال
بتقوللك انا بتطلع لي رجل قلت لها اه يا
ماما ان شاء الله بتصير لك رجل صارت تقول
انا بدي البس بوت كيف بدي البس بوت صارت
تقوللي صارت تقوللي بتطلع لي رجل قلت لها
اه بعملك رجل ان شاء
الله